devant ce qu'ils t'ont qingdao les
expose à un petit jeu qui est
extrêmement rigolo avec michael aux
beaux jours mais kahlo oui bonjour
françois guy bardon au losange
extrêmement sage et avoir une bombe sous
les yeux et mika devant ses yeux il a le
manuel pour désamorcer cette bombe le
manuel fait 23 balles il va devoir
chercher dedans pour me permet de
désamorcer la bombe et c'est parti
unique à la bombe la ccl l'a toutefois
un monde donc ça va être extrêmement
simple à faire tu es prêt à bien lire
son manuel mais emmanuel et d'ailleurs
ok c'est parti il ya deux quatre six
fils six fils en bas à droite évoqué
syphilis est ce qu'il ya un lien fils
john williams yahia plusieurs fils john
ya pas de fil rouge
si un fil rouge sinon coûts plus bas que
coûte le quatrième j'ai assez bon ça
marche et que les cadres aient savoir
s'est faite bouton presse vas-y hockey
est ce que vous seriez plus ses erreurs
erreur en bas à gauche ya quatre petits
boutons ou sous pression c'est abusé 1 6
1 au truc on dirait un smiley qui
sourient ou qui tirent la langue
wow quelle est la ou le dernier c'est un
b et la barre du bessat teintées aussi
ok c'est bon alors tu fais 6 ensuite ces
bombes et way point d'interrogation
ouais ouais il est allé chez moi ok et à
chaque fois j'ai vu sur le bouton
maintenant ouais c'est assez alors le
bouton en fait faut pas que tu appuies
n'importe comment tu mois de quelle
couleur il est il est blanc mais lui
comme un connard en fait voyager quand
mdp en plein milieu sait pas ce qui va
le perdre au liban à merde
est-ce qu'il ya deux patries sur t'avons
away il ya deux pylônes et la 3d pina
leur veto à l'afrique a plu ok ça
s'appelait je relâche gorge en
l'achetant nom du mois et quelques
couleurs les jo john john john ouvert
ses pages ouvertes libéré lorsque le
compte à rebours 1,5 dans la position
qu'elle comptait 15 chacun
ok ok deckers un café sur quelques
autres
ok c'est parti vite diallo ses fils il
ya cinq rouge et noir il ya un fil jaune
ou par non ok s'il n'y a pas de pigeons
est ok cherche le dernier serial number
tutea y est roi et la fonction shift 2
plus tôt mais l'un perd 3 ok bah oui
casse le marché deuxième module c'est
des filles cette fois ils sont à la
verticale et y en a 6 3 blancs de bleus
un rouge
ok y'a pas de fichage des regards des
médias il y a trois fils où il ya une
petite étoile en dessous mais en avril
on s'en bat les couilles troisième fils
il s'est rien passé lazio ne sait pas
lui mais c'est grave au maire demain c g
joue le jeu c'est la troisième avec cinq
modules béziers après ces maudits lève
donc c'est bon oh ouais pas ouf c'est
d'abord au japon via un module est un
écran vert avec des lettres de sully à
marquer hlx qui loupa quoi ah non hockey
ici dit ok bien le truc de talent avec
les quatre petits boutons là et les
symboles du bouton m'a dit attention mon
client n'a c1 c'est à l'envers avec un
carré de dahouët y en a c'est un as mais
sur la barre de milieu du ier petite
barre verticale at on attend puisque
quelque chose le colosse
allez y en a un autre on dirait un un
[ __ ] mika a trouvé un petit barre
horizontale au milieu de la barre
verticale et c'est relié à un triangle
qui est sur un dogme iron man et celui
en bas à gauche on dirait un ces deux
barres verticales qui sont reliés par un
petit roeulx milieu et sa part aux
couilles en bas à droite
après ça va j'ai déjà vu est ce que
c'est un y à anvers oui oui ça y saga
avec safari gate agréable tous couru à
wave y
ouais c'est pas ça est-ce que ça
ressemble à m
à lombez non ok ça n allant vers des
cieux peut-être hockey a way
m non c'est pas ça s'est passé
ok ok 1 ouais y bizarre ouais ok c'est
bon c'est bon c'est le passé [ __ ] mais
qu'on a mis juste deux minutes reste
deux minutes cinq ans n'a fait qu'une
épreuve c'est pas moi qui avons le bike
oui moi je suis surtout venu d'asie
chiffre 3 elle est appelée sur le ton de
la 3ème position
c'est bon trois premières positions ok
un chiffre eu un sens que tu appuies sur
le même bouton que tu as puis à l'étape
2 donc sud avant nous et après
imposition le bouton genre la place du
bouton le chiffre le bouton ok c'est bon
c'est après imposition appuyé sur le
bouton dans la même position que vous
avez appuyé à l'étape 2 c'est ma salle à
manger rue sexy froid on est à quelle
étape 4e 4 et appuyez sur le bouton avec
la même étiquette vous avez appuyé étape
un âge à noter les positions rica c'est
qu'à toi c'était pas ça puis sur le
bouton avec la même étiquette que vous
appuyez et perd 2 c'était un choix
alors j'ai non j'ai délaissé mme
desrochers le truc des losanges pocket
en vol alors j'ai on dirait un truc on
dirait le odile est tournée on dirait
tournée avec une virgule au dessus du
nez ouais c'est un cul ouais c'est des
fesses
1 c'est qu'ils finiront signe du sida
cocq ouais alors tu fais à huy fesf est
sida
j'évite conflit c'est sûr que tu arrêtes
ta pas rater une batterie un [ __ ] je
m'étais et maintenant squeeze méga vous
try hard comme des bancs de d'amorçage
de cette dernière bombe trois fils un
bleu de blanc s'il n'y a pas de fil
rouge le deuxième ça c'est du temps
gagné
ok le truc des chiffres c'est parti un
deuxième position devant appel 4 donc à
deuxième position le bouton avec la même
étiquette vous avez puis à l'étape 2
donc ce qui donne un deuxième policier
au questionnaire le même chiffre que
vient d'appuyer justin ok c'est pas
c'est le rouge qui note c'est une
voyelle ou une wii appelé il ya pas de
voyage la couleur c'est le brochet qui
note deux fois le bleu ok c'est le rouge
qui clignote de trois fois plus que le
bleu c'est un peu un peu nul 1-1 voilà
voilà
allez la difficulté d'être absente
attente alors on a le goût la gabelle et
à la fin on m'appelle va pas passer tout
à l'heure mais cas j'ai une grande
nouvelle à t'annoncer aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui est un grand jour puisque tu
viens d'obtenir un diplômé car le
diplôme du meilleur coéquipier pour des
mines et des bombes bic a chuté de la
bombe de cette vidéo chat boum boum
comment tu t'appelles
c'est rare mais c'est long non je cours